[Music]
what made you realize you wanted to go
into psychology
okay a couple of couple of thoughts here
the first one is i think i've talked
about this on the show my dad was
homicide detective and a swat hostage
negotiator in the city of houston so
he was always dealing in the lives of
other people and so i just had a
ringside seat and he's also worked with
local church worked with local youth
organizations so he was always dealing
with people's challenges
and so at a young age i was fascinated
by what would drive somebody to kill
somebody or what would drive somebody to
be an addict or why did that person
choose to get in a fight i wanted to
know how people worked i liked learning
how people worked and more importantly
like that's a research psychologist i
wanted to be able to help
and so
um i want to be an fbi when i was a
little kid and
that didn't work out and so i went to
college the ultimately the
i wanted to help people but i didn't
want to go to school for 100 years
ultimately what switched was i was a
sophomore junior in college maybe junior
and i i mean i wish it was more
i wish it wasn't so it's almost
embarrassing i went and saw the movie
goodwill hunting
and i remember watching the interaction
robin williams character
shawna thinks his name and matt damon's
character
and
i mean matt damon's cool he's a genius
but i remember watching
robin williams
and i remember leaving that theater
saying
that's what i want to do
and
i went and changed my major on monday
and it was the close
i had to take x number of psychology
courses over the next year and a half
to maybe two years and i'd hustle
and so i ended up with a humanities
undergrad degree because that was the
best way they could cobble together like
dude you're already halfway through your
program
and so i ended up with enough psychology
courses so i could go to graduate school
i think you had to have 21 hours or 18
hours something like that to go to grad
school but when i look at the arc of my
career
i liked the idea of the what my whole
goal in life was before i took this
crazy job was to be the guy behind every
behind closed doors
so when somebody was working through
hard things in their life
they would call somebody and that person
would say i know a guy and i wanted to
be that guy no billboards no
advertisements i want to be the person
behind the person
and i wanted to not exist in the phone
book and not exist on the internet i
wanted some to be able to
see people and help
and
then i got a fancy job at a college and
so i took the quickest route i could go
and that was to get a phd in education
so i could be a college administrator i
want to be a college president for a
season
the further i got down that rabbit hole
the more my job was taken up whether it
was personnel issues or whether it was
student issues or whether it was student
family issues was psychology psychology
psychology i'm going to hurt myself my
your child just tried to kill themselves
i we just got a divorce i need you to
tell our my child
um
i have to tell you that your job
performance isn't enough and oh my gosh
now you're curl up on the floor and
you're weeping or i've got to let you go
and how do i do that with dignity i've
got to fire you how'd i do that with
dignity and let you retain your
respectability and we honor you in this
process so it was all about psychology
and it wasn't until i had my own
run in well i was just crippled by
anxiety i just my body said enough
that i became obsessed
from a from a research angle like what
is happening i want to know why this is
happening
and where is this heading and
so i started nickel and diming my way i
started taking class after class reading
book after book i just got obsessed with
it i think it was in 2010
um 2008 when i really went off the deep
end like i want to learn everything i
can about how the brain works and the
body works and the interaction between
nutrition and psychology and family of
origin and family systems and
mental health issues i want to i want to
know all of it how all that works
together and in many ways it's gotten
muddy or muddier and in many ways it's
gotten so much clearer
um but all along a trace all the way
back to me being a child
and
the two big neon signs one is when
there's a people are hurting you go in
you go in i got that from my dad you
head in
and then the i think i talked about the
show too the second one is my mom
had some restraints on her just because
of our
just her um upbringing that women didn't
need to go to college and so watching my
mom at age 40
go back to go to college the first time
and
in a way have her entire world shift and
change
and to see how does that happen and
what's the impact on family systems and
what's that impact on her and on
people like her and then on marginalized
i just got obsessed with psychology so i
had a ringside seat to it
and then i had family experiences and
personal experiences that led me to it
and then man i wish i wish i could give
you some great epiphany answer other
than i wouldn't saw good will hunting
and i remember leaving saying i want to
do that
and that's my journey with psychology
and now i have a radio show
so great just like i drew it up who
knows it does say it does
man
follow what you love follow what you
love
work takes care of itself follow what
you love